The story goes that the
first temple to stand at
the site in the image
was built by a race of
little people known as
the Menehune.
Thousands of men were
needed to construct this
temple. Thousands of
them.
And it took one night,
according to legend.
Studies suggest that in
the 12th century the
temple is rebuilt and
its walls heightened to
30ft. It is dedicated to
the God ku a deity who
shapeshifts between
human and shark form and
is known as the eater of
islands.
He is a particularly
fearsome God.
He's the God of war.
Ku was probably the most
important of these
Hawaiian gods and only
the King.
The priesthood and the
highest nobles were
allowed access to the
temple.